>> Shannon: IN ADDITION TO
SIGNING THE PACKAGE SENT BY
CONGRESS, HE ALSO SIGNED WARTIME
AUTHORITY.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US.
>> THANKS SHANNON, GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
AS SOMEBODY WHO IS STILL
DEPLOYED AND ACTIVATES AS A
NATIONAL GUARDSMEN, WHAT THIS
COULD MEAN.
I KNOW THERE IS A HESITANCE FROM
SOME PEOPLE WHO SAY THEY ARE KEY
IN THEIR CIVILIAN LIVES.
DOING OTHER IMPORTANT THINGS.
WHAT WOULD IT MEAN TO HAVE THE
NATIONAL GUARD?
>> I THINK THAT THIS IS GOING ON
A STATE-BY-STATE AS-NEEDED
BASIS.
THIS IS LITERALLY THE ROLE AND
FUNCTION OF THE NATIONAL GUARD.
TO BE ABLE TO STEP UP AND TO
PROVIDE ESSENTIAL SERVICES
DURING TIMES OF CRISIS JUST LIKE
THIS.
MY FIRST FOUR YEARS IN THE ARMY
NATIONAL GUARD WERE SPENT
SERVING IN A MEDICAL UNIT,
EMPLOYED TO IRAQ.
ALL OF WHOM, YES, THEY HAVE
CIVILIAN JOBS HERE BUT WHO ARE
READY TO RESPOND IN A WAY THAT
SOMETIMES ONLY THE
NATIONAL GUARD IS BEST EQUIPPED
TO DO SO.
AND IN STATES AROUND THE
COUNTRY, PEOPLE ARE STANDING
READY SHOULD THAT ACTIVATION
OCCUR.
MYSELF INCLUDED.
>> Shannon: YOU ARE A
MULTITASKER.
YOU HAVE BEEN HERE IN TOWN IN
WASHINGTON WHERE THE SENATE HAS
PASSED.
AND NOW WE ARE LOOKING AT A
THIRD PACKAGE ALREADY.
THERE WERE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PRICE TAG FOR THIS.
LET’S GET A LITTLE PERSPECTIVE
ON THIS BEFORE WE COMMIT
BILLIONS, TRILLIONS OF FUTURE
FORMS DOWN THE ROAD, WHERE ARE
YOU IN THIS WHOLE PROCESS?
WE’RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
THIRD PACKAGE.
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE’S
LIVES HERE.
WE’RE TALKING ABOUT THEIR HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND WELL-BEING.
I THINK OF PEOPLE ARE LOOKING
FOR PERSPECTIVE, LOOK AT WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN SOME OF THESE OTHER
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD.
AND LET THAT BE A WARNING TO OUR
LEADERS TO SAY HEY, WE NEED TO
TAKE ACTION NOW.
WE NEED TO TAKE ACTION TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT THAT WE HAVE.
THE MASKS, THE TESTING KITS,
THAT WE HAVE WHAT IS NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THE HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING OF THE PEOPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY.
AT NUMBER ONE, AND NUMBER TWO
FOR THOSE WHO ARE GETTING LAID
OFF.
FREELANCERS, UBER DRIVERS,
CONTRACTORS.
PEOPLE WHO ARE LOSING THEIR
LIVELIHOOD BECAUSE OF THIS
GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
WE NEED TO PROVIDE DIRECT AID.
I INTRODUCED A RESOLUTION LAST
WEEK BEFORE LEAVING WASHINGTON
SAYING THAT WE NEED TO PROVIDE A
MINIMUM OF $1,000 $1,000 TO CUT
TAPE AND BUREAUCRACY AND MAKE
THE BEST DECISIONS FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
I AM GLAD TO SEE PRESIDENT TRUMP
REALLY STARTING TO PUSH FOR THIS
KIND OF DIRECT EMERGENCY.
A COUPLE OTHER QUESTIONS FOR
YOU, FIRST OF ALL AS WE HAD
CONGRESSMAN NUNEZ EARLIER, THERE
ARE NO TWO MEMBERS WHO HAVE
TESTED POSITIVE.
YOU HAVE ALL BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER IN VERY CLOSE QUARTERS,
WILL YOU GET TESTED?
>> I THINK THAT EVERY MEMBER OF
CONGRESS SHOULD GET TESTED.
I THINK THAT MORE PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY SHOULD GET TESTED BOTH
THOSE WHO HAVE SYMPTOMS AND WHO
ARE CONCERNED, MAYBE THOSE WHO
DON’T HAVE SYMPTOMS BUT WHO HAVE
BEEN EXPOSED TO SOMEONE WHO HAS.
OR IF TRAVEL TO SOME OF THESE
COUNTRIES AND COMMUNITIES IN
THIS COUNTRY WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING SOME OF THESE
OUTBREAKS.
WE HAVE TO LEARN FROM WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN HAS WORKED IN
SOUTH KOREA FOR EXAMPLE WHERE
THEY HAVE TESTED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE AND
THEREFORE BETTER ABLE TO CONTAIN
THIS VIRUS AND TO REDUCE THE
THREAT AND THEY ARE ONE OF THE
FEW COUNTRIES AT THIS TIME OF A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC THAT ARE
ACTUALLY SEEING THEIR NUMBERS
DRASTICALLY DECREASE.
I THINK IT’S IMPORTANT FOR
CONGRESS TO EXERCISE THAT
LEADERSHIP, THE CDC, THE FDA.
AT THEY TO BREAK THROUGH THE RED
TAPE AND GET RID OF THIS VERY
NARROW TESTING CRITERIA.
ANY OF THESE OTHER THINGS THAT
ARE STANDING IN THE WAY OF
PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO KEEP
THEMSELVES AND THEIR LOVED ONES
SAFE.
>> Shannon: THERE IS GROWING
NOW VERY VERBAL PUSH ON
SENATOR SANDERS TO DROP OUT AND
TO ALLOW HIM TO BECOME THE
NOMINEE AT THIS POINT.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> SENATOR SANDERS WILL MAKE HIS
OWN DECISIONS.
I WILL BE MAKING AN ANNOUNCEMENT
ABOUT MY FUTURE CAMPAIGN
TOMORROW MORNING.